Rainbow six Xbox in close-quarters
battle and hostage-rescue assembled from
Special Forces teams around the world
the counterterrorism units
reiha-sama are gloomy and get off
tachanka is armed with a modified are
p36 machine gun that can be mounted on a
stand to allow a broader range of motion
there might be a reason why this piece
has been around since the sixties
equipped with an HDS flip sight glass
can support his team from a distance he
takes pride in his accurate attention to
detail when you thread to Patrona if it
moves it will go down Capcom is equipped
with a homemade explosive trap that can
be deployed in doorways and windows to
incapacitate enemies stone gusty captain
knows exactly how to catch his prey
when collateral damage isn't a concern
fuse is the man stop no Casilla please
ahead he can mount a Fester charge on
floors or walls to release mini grenades
in multiple directions
imagine it's physics when it comes to
serving their country
Spetsnaz operators know that the
greatest honor is personal sacrifice
her gymnix dish
you